[Music]
hi i'm chris after 10 years working in
corporate finance i quit my job sold
everything i owned and moved here to
live in the wilderness of alberta canada
i want to get away from it all move out
of the burbs wake up in the morning to
the bugs and the birds collect wood for
a fire and bathe in a stream i'll be
getting back to nature i'd be living the
dream i can forage for nuts i can live
off the land
i meet a tiny squirrel letting me from
my hand learn the names of the plants
learn the names of the trees
this one's ian and this one's keith get
away from it
all live while i'm young ignore calls
from my wife and my infant son i got a
new life now it's one i prefer
living free in the wild just me and my
squirrel i struggle getting food finding
berries and nuts feeling hungry got a
rumble in the middle of my gut pull the
squirrel over betray his trust
kill him cook him eat him and cry and
disgust i be living my life in the
wilderness
going off gritting only for stress i
know a lot of your word killed for this
forget about the past our life afresh
quit the rat race leave it all behind
break free all your chains don't be
confined be wild the way that
man's designed and live in a wilderness
i want to get away from it
all like a lumberjack just me and my
hemingway paperback
collect my own water [ __ ] in a hole and
weep as i do it cause i feel so alone
be depressed repress my feelings then
chop down keith and chop down ian
feel even more lonely cause my friends
are gone i miss them so i'm heading out
to make a new one get away from it all
roam round in the forest in a few days
come across a wandering tourist
build a fire in the grey outdoors swap
stories where the tourists make
delicious s'mores
make a new friend feel happy again
barely even think about noah and jen
my friend tries to leave in the
following struggle i crush his skull
with a rock so i pick up a shovel i'll
be living my
life in the wilderness going off grid no
need for stress
i know a lot
[Music]
i wanna get away from it all and jump in
a lake so i gather up stones for
additional weight
write a note in blood on the back of a
leaf apologizing to my mates break down
with grief as i stand on the shore
thinking no one cares
out the corner of my eye a friendly bear
talk about the things in common that we
like to do
turns out she's killed squirrels and
tourists too get away from it all with
my grizzly friend
develop a bond but you know how it ends
i had sex with the bear then married the
bear had a cup with the bear then i had
an affair
with a different bear so i got divorced
from the bear wanted custardy a kid so i
went to court with the bear now i'm
paying huge amounts of child support at
the bear
moral of the story is don't have sex
with bears